we begin with this rescue crews are
searching for people trapped in the
rubble after a deadly earthquake hit one
of the world's most exotic tourist
destinations the US Geological Survey
says the magnitude six point nine quake
that the Indonesian island of Lombok and
shook nearby Bali just before 7:00 p.m.
local time last night more than 90
people are dead hundreds more are
injured the destruction is widespread
thousands of homes are damaged or
destroyed tourists from around the world
are stranded Ben Tracy is following this
unfolding story from Beijing Ben good
morning good morning so this is the
second deadly earthquake to hit this
same island in just the past week and
there have now been nearly 200
aftershocks since the latest quake hit
Sunday night
the quake struck the island of Lombok at
around 6:45 p.m. local time and rattled
nearby islands including the popular
tourist destination of Bali sending
panicked crowds into the streets Sunday
night we just got really big it was like
a truck passing by but then it got
really happy and also the noise was
crazy so I thought okay this is bad news
an earthquake
while many slept outside in the
aftermath crews and volunteers dug
through the rubble to pull survivors to
safety damage to hospitals forced
doctors to treat the sick and wounded
outside by moaning a mob of people
packed the shores to board ferries off
the island of gili trawangan and medical
teams evacuated the injured from nearby
islands by boat frightened tourists
rushed to evacuation points trying to
reach the Lombok Airport
determined to leave as quickly as they
could now I just want to go and somewhat
save somewhere I know I'm not gonna be
the risk of natural disasters
whatever it takes ready now so far no
foreign tourists are among the dead but
officials in Indonesia say they do
expect the death toll to rise and that's
because they have not been able to get
rescuers into some of the areas that
were most hard-hit what Ben Tracy for us
thank you Ben